one good morning Millennials and gen Z
welcome back to the toast happy Thursday
hope everyone's having a fabulous day we
are because we are both sitting in our
iconic our historic our legendary TMT
sorority sweatshirts that have been
restocked on our website for the first
time in a millennia shopmorningtoast.com
they just launched hey Jax how you doing
I'm doing good thank you so much I love
to see this energy that you're being
considering that it's been a morning
it's been a morning we've had a very
full mornings
Etc
and I'm so glad to be back with you back
with the stripes Brothers we didn't know
if they were going to cooperate for this
episode but it seems as though they're
laying down their weapons and they're
gonna get their [ __ ] asses up and
work so we've got the streis Bros we've
got the toast it's Thursday again we
just launched for the first time in a
long time we haven't restocked these
sweatshirts in a while
um our classic sorority crewnecks are
now available on shopmorningtoast.com in
addition to a new item that we teased
yesterday on the toast then we
officially dropped this morning you can
check out pictures of it on our
Instagram they're onesies they are you
know products for The Mamas out there
because the mamas deserve nice things
they do and so the onesies we have blue
and pink and they say thank you Mama and
they're for the little Bebes who can't
thank their mothers but the mothers are
doing everything for them and it's just
meant to be like a little reminder
throughout what might be you know a
hard day that you are thanked and you
are loved and you are appreciated so
shopmonitos.com merch check Thursday we
got a great show last night was the
season finale part three of The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills reunion
which we both watched and we'll be
recapping of curse of curse also I'm
wearing my new shoes which I'm so
excited about because they're so cute
and I paired them with my merch and um
we're both just looking sickening like
our looking second let's just put it
simply you know simply put simply put
we're gorgeous girls but that's also
what happens when you wear this
particular sweatshirt because it can be
styled so many ways I wore it on Monday
with leggings obviously casual maybe a
little
ankle a lot calf sock and a and a
sneaker so cute or you can be gorgeous
elegant Queen in your trousers that's
the thing when you shop at
shopchanel.com the possibilities are
truly endless yes or you could be like
me just a gen z icon in your wide leg
pants that um let's talk about doing a
little tight let's talk about um let's
talk about you and gen Z and also kind
of like a singenzi because I don't even
realize we had people who listen to the
show who are a part of gen Z I feel like
we're so Millennial that make you so
happy to learn it honestly made sense
you know since I'm so big on Tick Tock
of course they probably came here
because of you being a thought leader
and then they stumbled upon you and
we're like wow our gen Z leader our big
sister that's what they're calling me
they're calling me gen Z's strict older
sister the comments yesterday poured in
I again was shocked by how many gen Z
listeners we have and that they really
love your girl and they they like me
they like they really like me they
really like me and the reasons that they
were citing like I really felt scene
they were like we love how much you're
passionate about things how how much
thought you put into your thoughts and
that you're like our strict older sister
and gen Z colon There's Hope yet I told
you gen Z might save us all they might
save us all so that was really hopeful
to see yesterday it was an eye-opening
day and I feel like we need to add them
to our opening intro good morning
Millennials and gen Z
no there's so many of them there's not
then they're overlooked there's
thousands no we can change our intro
because like I think enough has changed
here at the toast we need to stay the
same for a while oh you know me and like
a change of verse girly okay too many
changes like we're gonna be we're gonna
stay in this position for a while okay
that's fine because you came on this
change-filled journey so I won't push
you too far you know and it's like
outside my comfort zone like Rebrand new
name like I hate change but it's going
well so far yeah I would say so I would
say so
we got a great show we do we have some
interesting stories today Beverly Hills
recap you're still watching Love is
Blind oh my god did you see my Instagram
stories yeah something crazy happened
did you watch him on with volume I did
but then I started to be worried about a
spoiler no it's not a spoiler there's
this girl Nancy I won't say who she's
engaged to but like we I just got to the
part where like they're out of the pods
and they're on like the honeymoon phase
which is like where it gets really
awkward like people like spending the
night together for the living together
so Nancy and the man that she ends up
with um are in the bathtub like in
bathing suits like being cute and he's
like trying to be sexy and I think at
one point she farted because like a
bubble popped up and she was like oh
but it could have been just like the
drain or whatever like she was talking
about the dream before then like they're
being sexy he's like leaning in and
she's like have you ever like clogged a
toilet like with your poop
and he was like she said yeah he was
like yeah
she's like and like what did you do
about it like have you ever clogged a
toilet where there's no plunger and he's
like I don't know
she's like oh because I did one time and
like there was a really big poo and like
I think she called it a dookie with like
a wad of toilet paper so like I took the
toilet brush and like I broke up the
poop until it went in the hole and it
was just like so funny
foreign
and I'm not one of these girls who's
like girls don't poop but like you know
when you're courting someone you know
you're engaged you're like having sex
for the first time like I do feel like
it's you know becoming of you men or
women to just act right and she was
acting wrong she was acting wrong it was
really it was jarring me in bed and like
we're physically like not okay we were
like cringing that's horrendous they
will not last of course not is going to
leave her but also like some spoilers I
read was that like he's problematic too
okay well until you tell me something
equally jarring he will be leaving her
it it was really like it takes a lot to
shock me like when it comes to reality
TV because I feel like so many things
are so contrived and like things that
are like shocking aren't actually
shocking and it's just like clickbaity
this was a moment that really stopped me
in my tracks like I like cultural shift
it was a cultural shift you know what it
was a cultural [ __ ] I think it's a
cultural shift to say that like we've
gone too far things are too we know too
much yeah it was such a weird sequence
of events like I can't even like put
towards how confused I was feeling I
feel sick it was a sickening Moment Like
a moment that would make one sick so I'm
actually really enjoying Love's blind
and I do think I might end up finishing
it just because like whenever I get into
bed yeah no I'm not invested but
whenever I get to bed it's like I'm not
watching anything else I'm all caught up
on everything and there are some couples
that I love like the Israeli girl I love
and then there's another couple I won't
spoil anything yeah but um the girl who
dances and the guy who works in okay you
you guys know what I'm talking about
um look I really like them okay great I
think they might have a bill to last
because they kind of look like siblings
and I feel like couples who look alike
couples who who are right for each other
start to look alike yes that's true but
I don't know if necessarily they start
out looking alike that's a little
different no but I didn't see it at
first but like now I do yeah but then
once they're together they start to look
alike and that's nice yeah it's cute
that's something you don't start to look
like they're dogs like me and Bryce and
Bruna looks like you and Thea definitely
looks like me I think Thea looks like
Ben me too I also think Magnolia also
really looks like her mother Bachelor
and snitch has started dressing like
Magnolia and only Magnolia huge and like
creams and Browns and nudes yeah
they are becoming to become one to
become One
Two Is Better Than One do you remember
that Boys Like Girls album
I used to be left drunk but now I'm
hungover I remember the hits
um I like that was like my first album
that I listened to like ever in full
over like one summer at summer camp and
I swear I could still like retain all
the words that was such a good album I
was such like an emo kid like I was
misunderstood you were not like other
kids no and like I just used to like put
my iPod Nano headphones in and like rock
out to Boys Like Girls and just
disassociate yeah Another Place Another
Time and like look out the car window
pretending I was in a music video that
was so me yeah I was like so that girl
you should film a music video for one of
your songs and it's just you looking out
the car window the whole time it would
just be like a dream fulfilled I love I
love love that idea
um Theo has to be in it too obviously
he'll be looking out the other window of
course tongue hanging out of his mouth
yeah
um so I feel like we can dive in we have
some some good stories and I really want
to talk about Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills because it was like so Twisted
agreed so without further Ado though
Where Are You Bruno is right there
where are you
Theo is a sweetheart
where is THU crunchy Angel Dora
hi muffin Dora we've got the boys it's
gonna be a good day you guys it's
Thursday we're almost through the week
congratulations even though it's this is
the least amount of a do in a while I
feel yeah even though whenever we were
talking about the segments this week
that people loved A lot of people do
love the pre Fast Five banter who
doesn't but the thing about it is when
it's done it's done
it's beautifully sad like really it's
stunning
so now without further Ado it is time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know and today's episode is very
appropriately brought to you and
sponsored by Caraway home cooking
products so if you watched our Vlog
making Taylor Swift's favorite cookies
you know we were we're using Caraway
yeah yeah for the the baking the baking
pan so we have tons of Caraway
homemaking products I think they're
cookware set and their baking set are
two of the most fabulous products on the
market right now obsessed Beyond if you
are ready to ditch the chemicals then do
so with Caraway homes non-toxic cookware
and bakeware collections so you can make
healthier cooking a piece of cake
Caraway homes non-toxic kitchenwares are
all designed for the modern home they
feature a chemical free ceramic coating
so food can be prepared with peace of
mind that know hard to pronounce
compound is going to be leaching into
your food ingredients all of their sets
come equipped with easy access storage
solution so there is no stacking
required everyone has that cabinet where
it's just like pandemonium not with
Caraway especially because you don't
need as many pots and pastries because
they do it all gone are the days of
misplacing your Lids so the two sets the
cookware set and the bakeware set the
cookware set is a modern and chemical
free iteration of the traditional 16
piece set but it's boiled down to the
four Essentials which is a fry pan saute
pan saucepan and a dutch oven like I
just appreciate like really them only
giving you the crap you need like yeah
the way we've been like kind of
bulldozed by consumption corporate
consumption like nobody needs 16 pots
and pans they'll stink and they all
stick and also what I learned recently
is that most non-stick cookware is
extremely toxic yeah it has chemicals
and metals and Caraway is nothing like
that it's nothing of the sword it's
toxin free so their bakeware set is the
assortment of non-toxic baking
Essentials that every modern kitchen
needs so you can get to baking your
goods without any of the bads um so
again they're non-toxic it's easy
cooking the Ceramics natural slick
surface means minimal oil or butter for
slide off the pan eggs and easy cleaning
they are super well-loved over 25 000
people have raved about the Caraway
Kitchen products it is time to try for
it try it for yourself we've both used
it and neither of us are like cooking
Wizards it's not a prerequisite to be a
good Chef just your house will thank you
it'll be clean obviously non-toxic but
also just easier even if you aren't a
good Chef I do feel like the Caraway
products do make it a little easier yeah
um and of course we have a code for you
so cover up mistakes you know you burn
the bottom right no you didn't no you
didn't visit carawayhome.com com TMT to
take advantage of this limited time
offer for 10 off your next purchase this
deal is exclusive for our listeners so
visit carawayhome.com
TMT or just use code TMT at checkout
Caraway non-toxic cookware made Modern
made Modern we're going to be using
Caraway this weekend when we make our
special cookies oh yeah we were going
through I was feeling like a real like
Suburban mom no it's not super Homemaker
Jackie had these gorgeous cookbooks it
was Aina it was Harvest they were two
half big Harvest one Magnolia table and
an Ida an item but I don't and we didn't
look at her desserts I do her for the
main dish so I looked through the
dessert sections of all the books and
picked out the ones that looked best in
the photos and I think we ended up with
half-picked Harvest signature chocolate
chip cookies they looked so good we're
gonna make it this weekend
um and I'm just excited because I love
cookies like I really do and I'm just
like loving baking and cooking with you
for you for the family you've been doing
an excellent job especially when
Everyone likes what you've made there's
really no better feeling there's no
greater compliment and and fulfillment
from nourishing the people you love with
like good [ __ ] it's giving lessons in
chemistry
also my idea for doing a patreon ASMR
video is still out there I got a lot of
people saying no but I got a lot of
people saying I haven't seen the
discourse yeah no people are like please
um I'd rather die and other people were
like yes queen and I think that's ASMR a
very divisive category of content you
know what would be a funny patreon
episode it would be two episodes to
Choose Your Own Adventure would you
rather you can listen to Claudia's ASMR
episode or me talk about books I think I
won you think yeah
that would be really funny
I could never listen to that I don't
even hear me I couldn't listen to it no
you listening to it in real life is not
fun but when it picks up on the mic like
it has ear triggers like this sounds
like nothing to you
but on the mic
it's a crispy I think these mics not
might might not be right for ASMR sure I
think sure is surely wrong for ASMR I'm
sure they make ASMR specific microphones
are you sure that they do I'm not sure I
am not sure I'm simply not sure what
kind of business is that am ASMR
specific microphone it's not ASMR
specific microphones it's like a
different type of audio microphone like
if you were if we wanted to record every
sound in this room not just our why
these are such great podcast microphones
that sure makes is because they isolate
our voice like if there's a phone
buzzing in that other corner you won't
hear it yes so it's just like a little
lesson in audio this is your Tech
segment from your local AV girl yeah
so we'll make those cookies we'll let
you know how it goes and we'll be using
Caraway bakeware amen which I [ __ ]
love okay bakeware I [ __ ] love it
I got it Caraway bakeware I'll do it I
don't give a [ __ ] I'll do it
Caraway bakeware you'll eat it and
you'll like it totally guaranteed okay
let's get it sorry you'll eat it and
you'll like it guaranteed
a Delirious kind of day you know yeah I
think those aren't peeps faves too
our first story Prince Harry's Memoir
cover title and release date have been
revealed I honestly did not think reveal
yourself did not think this was going to
happen until now we have a cover title
and release date penguin random house
has revealed the title and cover of
Prince Harry's long-awaited Memoir so
we'll start with the title it's called
spare
as in the air and despair and he is the
spare because he's not the heir because
he's second to the air thus he is the
spare one thing about me is I actually
really like when people take the thing
that that kind of plagues them and
they've been mocked about and like owns
it like reputation and the snakes like I
actually really like that that's not why
people mock him for being a spare no but
it's like the thing that people think
about you do you know what I mean it was
once the thing that people thought about
him right and then I'm sure it shaped
his upbringing your way of taking your
power back is like owning that thing yes
however and so I love when people do
that it's like one of my favorite like
ways to like turn the tables I just
don't think this is particularly well
done maybe if it was called the spare
but the word spare doesn't feel like a
complete book title to me do you know
what I mean yeah it's a word also he was
the spare five years ago now he's not
despair right uh like Louie is he's not
in line no but even before the kids were
born like he's no longer in line to the
throne because he has stepped away oh I
guess yeah he has him in the spare
technically but it's still like a stigma
you know yeah and it's still like how he
was referenced growing up right and I'm
sure this book will be mostly about his
childhood I imagine honestly it's going
to be a little disappointing because
people are looking for you know the exit
T and I feel like that will be the last
chapter and it's really going to be like
growing up in the palace the passing of
his mother yeah and all of the
responsibilities and pressures that he
faced so we also have a release date
which is January 10th 2023. oh my half
birthday that I'm thinking about turning
into my full birthday
you said that last year that you were
going to but then I don't really
celebrated your full birthday so like
but no that's but January is next year
oh well she would start it next year
yeah but then like I don't want to turn
20.
sooner than sooner yeah so that's right
into my plan I just hate having a summer
birthday scratch that scratch it and
then the cover was revealed and it's a
close-up photo of his thought she looks
very handsome yeah I'll show you guys as
best I can but also Google it
um and all it just says Prince Harry on
top and then spare at the bottom so
that's weird the name is Prince Harry it
wouldn't be like Harry Windsor right
Harry Mount Patton Windsor
I guess like Royals really haven't
written books that's like the whole
point so there's not like a precedent
that you can follow like oh well
Camilla's book was Camilla Parker ball
so I'll be Harry Windsor yeah
um I just think
even though colloquially yes your prince
you'll always be Prince Harry to us like
when you're putting pen to paper you
should do your name you're not a prince
if you abdicated your dude well I think
he still is a prince like in title only
he's not a working Prince but he's still
a prince
is the Duke
he's aren't they Duke and Duchess yes
but he was a prince because he was a
grandchild of the Monarch
but always because it's like was I just
always compared them to Edward but the
thing Edward King Edward like had
something to abdicate like Harry didn't
I I do think he's still even like in a
technical sense Prince Harry like if in
name only if King Edward his real name
was David if he wrote a book after he
abdicated and called himself King David
and the author was King King Edward yeah
no that would be incorrect that would be
factually incorrect but factually I
think he's still a prince
I'm just thinking like you know your
byline is your true god-given name right
um but again like I don't think anyone
would know that Harry Windsor is his
name I barely know that right no I think
he's also making a statement like no
matter what I do where I go like I'm
Prince Harry everywhere I go every smile
yeah I'm more fixated on the name I
really don't think it's that good I'm
also just like a hater to my core I
actually think it's pretty strong I
think it should have been spare the
crazy beautiful life of a royal thirst
monster one thousand percent
but I think it's a strong name and a
strong I think it could have been
covered it should have been like the
spare Diaries like like the spare or
even the Prince Harry the spare spare is
just like it's not Punchy enough
I disagree I think if it's Prince Harry
the spare it's just about him being the
spare but the it just being spare is
like
it could apply to other facets you know
like what I don't know like maybe
he was like sparing other people all the
time you know I just think I like the
idea I don't love the execution I think
it could have been punchier
I actually think I was pleasantly
surprised by the impact no I didn't
expect to care about the spare what do
we think Harry's writing process was
like I mean as a royal you're extremely
well educated so does that mean you
write your own book you work with a
writer a ghost writer definitely still
worked with a writer just because you
have an education doesn't mean that you
are a compelling writer yeah yeah that's
true and you can be a compelling writer
without having much of an education yeah
very true very true facts spin facts so
he definitely worked with someone like
shared his
experiences and feelings and they put it
into prose right
um like I want to say I am going to read
this but like I'm probably not up next
on my list of Memoirs is Matthew Perry's
I've been hearing like crazy stories
today there's a headline with a crazy
interesting factoid about what he
experienced so I totally want to read it
I'm not in like um a memoir headspace
but the next Memoir I pick up I will be
reading it especially because I just
like love friends
um I've heard and it's so crazy because
I wasn't really like I was alive but I
wasn't like a socially conscious person
to like understand the magnitude of
their Fame at that time right because
now I consider Matthew Perry like kind
of like a husband but at the time there
was no one more famous and so I think
it'll be really interesting to hear the
stories of like the parties like he was
that guy yeah he was Brad Pitt of the
moment yeah so I really that's what I
actually want to read I will read
Harry's Memoir based on the reviews of
other people not like the critics
reviews but like what the toaster say
about it if people say there's a lot of
tea what he what he focuses on what like
you know the revelations are but also
there's been a lot of
books written by people who have left
the palace the people who have worked
for Harry and Megan during their time
there finding freedom and I've no but
that was written by like Harry and
Megan's besties right right right and
I've been meaning to read some of those
books so I would want to if I read his
book I would want to read also like a
counter you know like just to get more
of a full picture yeah so it would be
more of a project than just reading it
would be a large undertaking yeah so but
if you guys tell me that it's worth it
and there's so much in here
um and we'll see how like we never saw
him before then sure I pick it up yeah I
mean this book is going to be like an
instant bestseller all that there's
gonna be so much tea around the time of
its release kind of like how Matthew
Perry is now it's gonna be like 10 times
worse than that yeah
um with like tidbits coming out to tease
the book so I feel like we'll find out
like what the major takeaways are in the
during the week of its release because
they release like the big juicy tidbits
right and so if the tidbits are actually
juicy I will pick it up if the tidbits
are like behind the scenes to what Harry
was feeling after he wore the Nazi
costume
it's leading action I mean
I feel like a lot of people glaze over
that but for me that's like ever present
in my mind because I'm a girl who
doesn't forget
um Harry Hamlin so I wonder if he will
talk about the Natsu costume like what
is one's thought process into thinking
that that's an idea you should move
forward with I'm curious about that yeah
that sounds good
we shall see let us know let us know if
he talks about Dimensions at all
mention it all are you ready for our
next story yes Taylor Swift has cut the
controversial fat scene from her music
video of after backlash Taylor Swift
removed a scene from her anti-hero music
video after several health professionals
and activists dubbed it fat phobic we
discussed it yesterday she steps on a
scale that called her fat instead of
displaying a numerical weight now when
you view the music video on Apple music
the that scene is scrubbed from the
video
so I don't really agree with that and my
thoughts on it are on yesterday's
episode and I do want to thank everyone
for like the feedback whether you agreed
with me or not it was all very
respectful and I so appreciate that
um
however
if you're gonna take it out but not
address it like
it's kind of weird to me like and I know
she's not like a queen who addresses
things she's like is very you know
private and she doesn't make lots of
statements but to to edit it and not
make a statement about like her thought
process on why she did it I do feel like
that's kind of weird but I also kind of
feel bad like in a way like we silenced
her like this was her journey her
experience a music video about her life
and her thoughts and we totally
invalidated it being like you are
upsetting me I'm triggered and so
someone who uses art to like Express
their thoughts and feelings we said your
thoughts and feelings aren't valid take
it out like that's like really [ __ ] up
to me I I don't agree with taking it out
but I also don't agree with like taking
it out and then like not explaining
right if it was so bad that you actually
had to edit your music video take it
down and re-upload it like that's how
you know big of a mistake you made then
you should address it like not just do
it and not say anything it's confusing
it's confusing I think
it's a little crazy that she had to take
it out like same I saw a tweet I thought
there are a few comments in this article
that I wanted to share
um someone who was this person she is I
found it a social worker specializing in
eating disorder she said having an
eating disorder doesn't excuse fat
phobia it's not hard to say I'm
struggling with my body image today
instead of I'm a fat disgusting Pig
um and someone else said I saw someone
say that she could have put not thin
enough and I think that would have been
more in line with what she was trying to
get across anyways on top of not being
offensive I just feel like to be honest
I don't really give a shred of a [ __ ]
what you think about someone else's
experience now we're just like getting
so into the weeds it's like you can't
say fat but you could say not thin
enough and you can't say this but if you
had said that it would have been better
it's like it's all saying the same thing
and like people just like to like they
get obsessed with semantics and they
just like abuse language and it's like
it's a it's you're saying the same thing
but you can't say that word right but
it's like phrasing it this way is more
easy for you to digest so everyone in
the world should tiptoe around you even
though we're saying the same thing but
also I saw someone say I feel like there
are a lot of people who maybe have
struggled with an eating disorder and
they're saying like this triggered them
I've also seen people say I've struggled
with an eating disorder and it's so
refreshing to see Horrors like Taylor
who I think is so gorgeous and slim and
perfect that she goes through these same
things just like me and it makes me feel
less alone and you know quote unquote
normal the tweet that I saw that
resonated with me was it's from Stephen
osola it's beyond [ __ ] up that we've
reached a point where an artist can be
guilt-ridden over the portrayal of their
own trauma that they sanitized down
their art to make everyone feel
comfortable yes but that when I read
that like then a part of me becomes
disappointed in Taylor it's like no
standard for how you feel your
experience like and instead of just
acquiescing because everyone like made
you feel something type of way when
really you didn't do anything wrong but
it's your experience no and also like I
think as a society we really need to
start getting comfortable being
triggered like the expectation that
every piece of media you digest every
art every everything that you're going
to leave your house and see all these
things and everything should be designed
to make you feel comfortable I think
that's unreasonable it's my favorite
quote friendly where it's like being
triggered and being offended is a
consequence of leaving your house like
the world is not designed to make you
feel comfortable everyone has things
that that trigger them whether it's this
eating disorder whether it's grief
whether it's anything like we all have
different life experiences and a part of
being human is having trauma and I just
think like the the way we're expecting
everyone to accommodate us is
unreasonable I think we're making
ourselves actually weaker in doing that
because of course a huge part I think of
healing is being able to be triggered
and and confront it and work through it
and move past it instead of tiptoeing
around it constantly like you know side
swiping it and then anything that just
immediately like makes us uncomfortable
like we demand it be a raced and changed
there are so many people we've all been
through so much everyone has different
triggers it really took away every
single trigger people could not speak
people could not act right so while I
think at its core like the idea of like
trigger warnings like I do think that's
like a nice idea I agree I do struggle
with also like thinking about how we're
really actually setting ourselves up for
failure yes because we're just going to
become weak and comfortable and nothing
is really and I don't know how you heal
in that like so I really do struggle
because I think at its core like the
whole concept of trigger warnings is
actually really nice yeah because you
don't want anyone to open up their phone
and have a bad day because of you right
so I get that but also I'm like but wait
like I actually think a part of growing
and healing like is being able to be
confronted by something that makes you
uncomfortable and being okay with it
right so I don't know I don't know what
the right thing is but I'm leaning
towards not trigger warnings honestly
like the more I think about it yeah I
think like a lot of things starts off in
Earnest even like we were talking about
my truth the other day yeah it's like
okay yes that is your truth but then
it goes too far and you're like well
does this make any sense and then also
like just the concept of
someone being offended therefore gives
them in like an entitlement do you know
what I mean yeah I don't know my
feelings are more important than yours
right right because I'm the offender I
was offended and my offense is more
important than your experience
expression
Etc totally totally so working through
these thoughts but that's where my brain
was at when I saw this agreed my brain
was at I was actually disappointed in
her because I think people need to start
putting their foot down I know it's like
we're all just like oh I'm telling you
I'm sorry like it's weird this one thing
because it's easier than to take a stand
for something I don't really care about
it right whether it says fat or not it
doesn't matter but it's the principle of
the thing and it's the scruples
screw
screw Scruples
I agree like I do wish she had but one
thing about Taylor's like she's not a
controversial Queen like she doesn't
make statements like that like she just
wants to like do her art and live a
private life and like I can also respect
that like her you know
protecting her Inner Peace by just
acquiescing like I can understand that
sure because the world is like such a
harsh place the internet is such a hard
harsh place that if you don't address
something like you're labeled fat phobic
forever yeah forever like those labels
are so toxic because people they're
they're more often than not a major
stretch and they people will will label
you that and keep it attached to your
name forever right and I think some
people like really can't survive that
yeah like not being able to come back
from this or not but I think Taylor this
is dropping the bucket for her so this
would have been a nice time to take a
stand and be like you guys it's it's my
life it's my art it's my video I stand
by what I said right and if you don't
like it then simply don't watch it yeah
because it's so important to always
remember like if you're so triggered
like you can turn off your computer you
can put your phone down and you can go
be not triggered in your backyard like
the personal accountability I think
they'll be triggered in the backyard
like with one of the birds or something
right no it's certain words and the bees
so true so true so that's my take on
that agreed our next story a little more
controversy for the Great British Bake
Off whatever would have thought but
that's such like a peaceful show I know
and and I think for so many people like
that's the point of the show but so the
Great British baking show judge Prue
Leith you know Pro Queen never saw her
in my life she's addressing the backlash
the show received after Mexican weeks so
they had an episode each week is themed
I've seen so many episodes it's hard for
me to recall all of the themes that
they've done or even some of that track
what is the concept of the British
payoff okay so theirs starts with 12
Cooks every week someone's eliminated
Bakers sorry and they're like the best
they try to get the best one yes and
each week they have to make three
different things the first challenge is
okay so say it was like here's an
example the first challenge would be
like chocolate chip cookies everyone
makes their best chocolate chip cookies
whatever recipe you want to follow sure
the judges come around and taste them
some people put a flare in them some
people [ __ ] up whatever then the second
challenge is a technical challenge the
judges will say follow this recipe yeah
here's a example of one technical
challenge they once had them make a
babka a lot of people didn't know what a
babka was they gave them a one paper
that's kind of like very Bare Bones
recipe and the ingredients and you have
to figure out what it is and how to make
it so that's the technical and then the
third is like big gangbusters you know
Hydraulics
Etc and the week is usually themed of
some sort so I think there's been like
80s themes there's always a random theme
and there are two hosts who are like
really make the corniest jokes at the
start of every episode I'm sort of a
nailed it girly than a Great British
Bake Off girly I love the Great British
Bake Off I do find it extremely common
in Serene so controversy has penetrated
the Great British thing after Mexico
week okay so first the episode starts
with The Two Hosts who are always making
corny jokes one says I don't feel like
we should make Mexican jokes because
people will get upset and the other one
says what not even Juan and the other
guys has not even won
okay then there the competition had them
making
um let me just get it in order of what
they made they made a
hold on pan Dolce steak tacos and a tres
leche cake Tres Leches right so there
was a lot of controversy surrounding it
uh an author Julie Powell tweeted just
watched the Mexican week episode of
Great British baking show and God it was
unbearable offensive offensive on a lot
of levels
um but then Anna Navarro from The View
said I love the British Bake Off Paul
Hollywood is my celebrity crush frankly
I was not offended by the way they
depicted Mexicans thought it was corny
but I was offended by the crimes they
committed against tacos and Tres Leches
okay horror you know the hosts were
wearing sombreros and uh okay
traditional so this is a thing
um it's it's cultural appropriation but
I I've noticed it on Tick Tock it's a
lot of these conversations are being had
around food and recipes because it all
started this girl was like I'm gonna
make this like fruity drink and she gave
it like a name and apparently the drink
that she made that like had went viral
is called agua fresca it's like a
Mexican drink and it's like fresh water
I don't know
um and so she got like you know her like
annihilated because she found this like
fruit drink recipe and didn't attribute
it to its Mexican Roots this girl uh
people descended upon her so in food
culture there's a lot of like stickiness
because food Cuisines come from
different parts of the world now I have
a differing opinion on this in general
because for me if my culture got a
television episode or you know a viral
Trend like I would be so Overjoyed I'm
like oh my God people are sharing like
there's so many great Jewish foods in
Jewish culture is so funny like I would
love a spotlight yeah on my culture okay
and what if The Two Hosts were wearing
like peace
oh that's a good question
no I don't think I would like that
but but but that's because payus is a
religious
so it's like disrespectful to wear it if
you're not because of religion maybe I
don't know if I'm seeing this
incorrectly what could be a a cultural
Jewish thing that's not a religious
thing right like a cultural Jewish thing
like if I wore I don't know like
like what is it the the Jewish
equivalent of a sombrero a yamaka but
that's religious yes yes
hmm wait this is an interesting
conversation let me think for one second
it's I don't know if there is an
equipment yeah because it is a religion
versus a nationality no I I do know that
in recent years sombreros have become
like a big No-No like I I did know that
um
but like see it's tough for me to
to
criticize because it's like not my
culture like if it was like I would be
[ __ ] annoyed like I would but I also
want to believe like this is all in good
fun and celebrating Mexican Cuisine you
know I mean I didn't see this episode
but given all the other episodes like I
think it really is an all in good fun it
is there isn't is all in good fun like
you know not meant to be offensive
whatsoever the approve said she
addressed it she said there would have
absolutely been no intention to offend
that's not the spirit of the show right
that's the whole concept of intent
versus impact like right you can digest
something and find it offensive but the
person who perpetuated it is coming from
a good place and like that counts for
something it does yeah but I can
understand like I guess if the payus
which I think is a more extreme
comparison like I would be furious
really but if the whole episode was just
a celebration of like Jewish children
Jewish food see we never get that it
would depend what entailed in the
episode but if it was you know a typical
episode that I've seen where it's like
they're learning about Bob because a
great example say the first thing was
like ruggle up and the last thing was
like learning about how they made
Regular and old Shadows like yeah I
think I would like that I would like it
but that's because we come from a
culture that doesn't get highlighted
right like it might be annoying to be
like you know Mexican where it's like
everyone is always like talking like and
using our recipes and then like not even
attributing it to our culture they did
attribute it yeah it's Mexican week yeah
yeah yeah no I don't really feel like I
can fairly compare because I don't I've
never seen an episode of TV that
separates like you know let's do Jewish
week or you know yeah
so I don't know I don't think it's fair
I guess people are entitled if something
rubs you the wrong way like it rubs you
the wrong way I think like most things
there are people who are offended by it
and then there are people who are like
like Anna Navarro was like just the food
looks bad like right I mean that's right
it's like how deep are you gonna
look into this right but I do think the
conversation about
food and culture is interesting because
it's like if you did Whittle it down all
the way like let's go all the way down
this road
um
can anyone make food from anyone else's
culture right no so that's a
conversation that's constantly being had
on Tick Tock and I don't cook so like I
don't really like pay attention to the
conversation that much but it's like
where you draw the line between like
wanting to respect like the the culture
in which this dish came from but also
then like so what you're just not
supposed to cook anything other than
American food right so it's an
interesting it's an interesting
conversation one that I really don't
feel strongly enough I don't know enough
about I don't know and um
ultimately that harms other cultures and
right because you want to celebrate that
and and highlight that right yeah so
it's an interesting conversation I was
actually just looking for it because in
the book I read tomorrow tomorrow and
tomorrow there was a really interesting
thing about cultural appropriation
because they made a video game about
like uh centering around like a Japanese
character and there were a lot of
Japanese influences and but it was early
2000s so then like later in the book
there's an interview and they're like it
was that cultural appropriation and I
wish I had the quote but the person who
made the game actually gave a really
interesting response about how like if
you do go all the way down that road
it's just you know white people making
things about white people and et cetera
Etc right you know and then you get to a
point where like it's like segregated
right right right no so I think there's
a respectful way to do it
um and I think some people take on both
sides like take it too far like right
demanding that only you know Asian
people can cook Asian food and it's like
well don't you want to share your
culture with the world right yeah no I I
think that um my opinion on this is
definitely biased because I wish more
people would take interest in and
highlight my culture you know got it so
that's my POV is skewed from that
perspective like oh you guys are
complaining like what about us
whatever happens to us you know that's
just my thoughts yeah it's hard to put
yourself in the situation right of
someone who's from a culture that's
constantly getting appropriate like
maybe it's [ __ ] annoying like maybe
it is you know yeah no but maybe it is
yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
Ariana Grande's titillating fans with
her new blonde hair as she transforms
into Glinda from Wicked because she's a
wicked talented that's by the way
someone called it yesterday when Claudia
was at the end of the episode talking
like that but guessed five stars maybe
listen to podcasts but in the morning
just leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are it
was giving John Travolta an adult
the wickedly talented Adele that's him
that was the craziest thing one of the
best nights of my life yeah like that
was like when internet meme culture was
like on fire and like people were just
making such funny content that was such
a great night yes so re is getting into
character for the forthcoming Wicked
movie with a dramatic blonde hair
transformation worthy of Glinda the Good
Witch it's a little early like the
movie's coming out what in six years in
six years but they're starting things so
she captioned it new earrings but
obviously everyone was quaking about a
blonde Ari no the way like I have so
much hope and faith in this wig like I
will be so disappointed if this movie
sucks like between arya's and Linda
could suck because the story is written
and it's a good story that's true but
like cats
was it a story worth telling I mean it's
the longest running Broadway show like
there has to be something there is there
it reminds me of uh Kimmy Schmidt me too
it's like a an open audition you just
come and dress like a cat and you can
take the stage
um but like between Ari being Glenda and
Cynthia arrivo being alphaba like I
don't know how it could be poorly done
like I'm so excited and with all the
time that they're taking right take your
time like really only if it's a plus
plus and it's two parts which is like
kind of psychotic that's the wizard
so excited you guys like
you can't think about it too hard no you
can't get excited right now it's you'll
lose steam it comes out Christmas
2024. yeah not even next Christmas
that's insane
insane love Island puts out episodes the
next day
that's such a that's so important to
always remember if they can do that
anyone can get us a movie by next
Christmas
no the fact that it doesn't take more
than
doesn't take less than two weeks to make
a movie like it's psychotic to me yeah
no like two weeks to film I'll give you
guys I'm gonna be generous two months to
edit oh I was gonna say a week no like
sometimes there's CGI you know and
whatnot things come up
um maybe a reshoot let me give you two
months and then I want to see it yeah no
it's like get it like speed it along
like the movie industry is like like
becoming more stretched out and like
longer to make films when like isn't the
technology getting better and like isn't
Elon Musk putting people on Mars like
right make it make sense make your movie
make your movie I mean we put together
an hour of the toast every single day
and it's like premium literally so like
are we movie stars yes did you not know
that no I thought we were just like
small screen no we're big screen girls
how scary that was so big near the big
screen we're too big for the small
screen
are you ready for our fifth and final
Story the final story
Ted it's Adele
our fifth and final story uh we have a
new music star on our hands Charlie
demilio has dropped her debut song if
you ask me to so in tandem with the
finale of the demilio show season two on
Hulu airing Charlie has released her
first song called if you ask me to in a
press statement Charlie detailed the
inspiration behind her foray into music
and why I now felt like the right time
to release a single quote I've always
loved music and Performing once my
online following started growing I was
able to Showcase my passion for dance
but I felt that with so many other
people entering the music space there
wasn't room for me however with my dad's
encouragement I got into the studio at
the beginning of this year just to
producing as a hobby with each writing
and recording session my love for the
process grew and I became incredibly
proud of the music we're making
so before I listen to the song This is
reminding me of another story from like
months ago where someone was putting out
a new song and I read like their Pratt
statement I'm having leadership I have
literally no idea oh my God it was like
someone's new song and like just their
statement about like you know the
process whatever and like I've quite
literally no idea I'm so sorry
well do you feel like um like this might
be like a little weird with Dixie well
yeah because that was Dixie's thing no
it was like Dixie's thing and like but
at the same time like social media was
like Charlie's singing then she involved
Dixie and her whole family and then they
all got different platforms and like
Charlie was doing dance and like I don't
think you can claim social media do you
know what I mean like Dixie has a
platform because Charlie did right and
because he would admit that I'm not
being like cheater right right but like
singing was Dixie's trade you know then
so like Dixie carved out like a space
for herself because everyone's like you
know just Charlie Sinister and then she
started releasing music and like the
[ __ ] was popping off like it was hitting
Billboard charts like it was actually
good [ __ ]
um she did a song with Wiz Khalifa so it
was very much like her thing and now
it's like Charlie coming in and
eclipsing that yeah I'm sure Dixie is
okay with it if Charlie's doing it yeah
but
it's a little surprising you know like
to really do everything I know I feel
like this is kind of Superfluous like
because it's been so late it's a nice
song you know it's pretty and I'm not
saying it's bad and I'm sure her voice
is beautiful but like I just feel like
from a branding perspective it's like a
little late after like Addison did it
and Dixie did it yeah it's like you're
doing too much like you're on Dancing
With the Stars right now the demilio
show like the social tourists like they
do a lot and like I just think like it
you could hold off but like maybe
someone who's managing her is thinking
big picture like
she didn't have the singing part yet but
if she added singing like she could be a
superstar Triple Threat she's saying she
has a huge audience I have a TV show she
could go on tour like if she has some
hits behind her and like maybe she's the
next Britney Spears and we just needed
some songs from her maybe like maybe
we're thinking Small Potatoes now now it
begs the question like why they wouldn't
be a singing Duo
the demilio sisters right the sisters
demilio DC CD The demilio Sisterhood
Sisterhood of the Traveling dimelions
that's it that's the title I just
thought this was interested me too
that's why I chose it yeah I mean for me
like Addison is the Britney like of Our
Generation like all these one hit wonder
no I know but what's so crazy is she has
like five more released five more
unreleased songs that keep getting like
done Tick Tock and they're so good I
know why doesn't she put out more
musicals to die for this boom boom out
to that bar it's like iconic pop music
why won't you release it I have
literally no idea and she's been using
the sounds like the like she knows
everyone like has heard them that
they're leaked she'll make tick tocks to
it I don't know like that one to die for
is like if it ever comes out like I'm
gonna be [ __ ] popping on the beach like
it's so good it's that for my neck to
die for this boom boom out that far it's
really like classic pop it's really good
even obsessed with so good you say
you're obsessed with me so I took a
second and I said me too
you're obsessed with me as much as you
you said you died for me I die for me
too
we were driving down Sunset you know I
love fast cars it's really like it's
good [ __ ] I know where's Addison's music
what do we want new music from Addison
when do we want it now we'll clip this
for tick tock and it'll go viral and
she'll see it and then she'll
she'll release music she will do her
thing but I want to do my thing someone
over at Team Charlie is thinking big
picture because if this goes well like
she could be the Gen Z Superstar selling
out stadiums the one thing about Charlie
that I think she needs to like
ameliorate if she's going to be this
like she needs to demelio right she's
very shy like even on the show like she
was working with a vocal coach and she
was so nervous to sing in front of the
vocal coach so was Dixie last season and
then Dixie got better and Dixie did like
the Jingle Ball circuit she's very shy
She's So Young um the thing about
Addison was like she didn't give a [ __ ]
like she was being like sexy dancer
older she's built for it confidence
comes with age yeah that's true also I
feel like
strangely a lot of the people who have a
lot of success in the public space are
shy people that's true you know I don't
know what that is like you would think
the ham like let's get the ham out there
but like people don't want the hammer
like yeah they want that like shot maybe
because they can relate to that person
more perhaps that's a good that's a
really good thing it reminds me of um
Queen Elizabeth and her sister because
remember when they were little kids like
her sister Margaret was the big
personality Elizabeth was very shy and
they were like well let's just let
Margaret be Queen like because she wants
to and I don't want to but it's like
Margaret would have been a terrible
Queen whereas Elizabeth was a wonderful
Queen because of that shyness and
preserved yeah totally I'm speaking of
Queens let's dive into the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills part 3
reunion recap
um it was a great episode I do feel like
overall the Aspen incident the reunion
in just the season in general were like
slightly overhyped on social media
because so many things have been leaking
and I was like we gotta see we gotta see
it and then we got to the part and they
didn't even have any footage so just
overall I did feel like this General
sense of like like kind of a let down
last night I thought Kathy came in guns
blazing she was really acting like a
politician like she was really very well
spoken her words were cutting she had a
couple really good reads like yeah to
Erica like oh who do you think people
are gonna trust me or you not even that
who has more credibility it was kind of
like a fire flames um insult the big
bombshell was that Erica claimed which I
had read on on Reddit or somewhere like
a forum Instagram prior to the season
airing was that why it was such a big
deal in
Aspen was at Kathy had this altercation
and she ended up calling the DJ the F
slur
um Erica said that she heard it none of
the other women heard it and I really
I just honestly like
I don't know if I believe it
but like as much as Kathy was like
coming out guns blazing she did like a
few like not so great moments um like
when she said you know that text that
you claim I sent you it's not in my
phone like Kathy was discovered like oh
you can delete text messages and Lisa
random was like what she totally sent
that text that wasn't even that
incredible I have no issue with that
text yeah it wasn't that crazy so I do
feel like she's definitely like lying
about a couple things but overall like I
do think Lisa Rinna is untrustworthy I
think she's coming from a bad bad place
I think she wants the heat off of her I
think she wants enough American so she's
dumping Kathy down the river and like
for me like I just like don't care like
any mistakes Kathy made like they're not
a mistake to me yeah I think that's the
thing it's like Lisa Rin is fighting to
prove that what Kathy like did happened
and I think she thinks that if she can
prove that Kathy said these terrible
things like that everyone will turn on
Kathy but um I'm sure nobody cares
believes I'm sure Kyle thinks that Kathy
said those things
um she doesn't care I think if the fans
even somehow could get proof that Kathy
said those things they wouldn't care
um people just are are advocating
towards cat happy over Renna it's not
even about whether she said it or not at
least not for me like about if she said
dorit is stupid or this or that like she
was on a tirade she probably said some
mean [ __ ] right
um I also believe that you can be angry
and say stuff that you don't mean I
don't think those are her true thoughts
about her sister and the group of girls
um but we are just writing for Kathy
yeah like at the end of the day it's
like she's fighting a losing battle
right now because like she could be 100
right and like the thing is we don't
care because we don't like you and we
like her like that's it
um I do wish Andy had like he was like
not doing an amazing job I do wish he
had pressed a little bit more like Lisa
Rena being so [ __ ] dramatic like
about everything it's like you've been
on the show for 10 years like you've
acted like an animal everyone here has
acted like an animal and you think
you're saying you're gonna get cancer
like you're being crazy you're crazy I
actually think that given the fact that
Rena is a big personality on the show
and not someone he could just like cast
aside I do think he he did ask that
question like you've seen so much and he
followed up he's like of everything
you've seen this was so crazy I was Bob
other that no one called Rena out for
abusing the word abusive uh just like
Chris can't violated yeah like no she's
was using big words that are like
actually like hold a lot of meaning and
you are not a victim of abuse right
you're not even really being bullied
you're literally like using these
grandiose words cancer right for a
nothing Burger a nothing burger and as
Kathy and Lisa both said when Kathy was
going off she wasn't mad at Lisa like
Lisa was her sounding board so she was
about a Kyle yeah she wasn't even saying
anything mean to Lisa about Lisa like
Lisa was just there Kathy was abusing
her glasses and yeah right
that's so true no Lisa's so [ __ ]
dramatic like for what yeah just to make
Kathy a villain
I think like Kathy coming in last season
and just like doing the least and
getting the most really rubbed a lot of
people the wrong way yeah and like it
made her a Target and I think this has a
lot to do with that
and it's just so funny how so many times
you've seen her on the show Kathy and
she's just like so go with the flow yeah
silly and the slippers and that like she
came out last night like a [ __ ]
sniper pointed like she had her points
made she came out with her purse she
looked like a gorgeous you know there
were no slippers in sight no no she was
really on one like she was like oh
everyone's gonna be like spend the whole
year dragging my name like I'll show you
and again like
did she do that [ __ ] like maybe do we
care
no we don't we really don't yeah that's
what it boils down to it was like people
just like Kathy yeah and I don't know
what she could do to make us not like
her but this ain't it right and so the
biggest thing now is the relationship
between Kathy and Kyle and it was crazy
to me how Kathy likely said these really
nasty things about Kyle yet Kathy is mad
at Kyle and Kyle's one apologizing and
I'm like how did this happen well that's
what Kyle soap said about it's like our
relationship is so dysfunctional like we
finally get to a good place I don't want
to start a fight because I'm it's kind
of like a little a little bit like
Melissa and Teresa like I don't want to
start a fight because like even if I'm
right which in this situation like
Kathy's wrong for blaming everything on
Kyle Even if I'm right like I have to
acquiesce and like I'm the one who's
gonna be in the wrong so like if we
could just not talk about it we could
continue on our peaceful sister Journey
that would be great right but I feel
like
Kathy like said that [ __ ] about Kyle
probably but why did she say it and it
was because of a season of Kylie not
having her back and they said and
putting her down putting her down they
had the conversation where it's like you
never pick up my calls and I feel like
Kyle may be in their personal life kind
of just like writes her off like in the
show she doesn't support her then the
tequila and Kathy hit her breaking point
and now she's upset about all of those
things and so yes it's being
overshadowed by the particular thing
that she threw but Kathy's still upset
that like you choose these girls over me
all the time and I'm your sister no it's
fair like Kathy's just not great at
making her point when it comes to Kyle
yeah and but I also think she doesn't
want to like go down that road
television and have this like intimate
no it's so conversation about our
relationship and it's and that's what
she kept saying she's like you wanted to
do it on camera so I did it on camera to
make it up to you but like I wanted to
do it on the phone and like in the
reunion you can tell that Kathy does not
want to have this family conversation on
television and I think that's so normal
I think it's there
but they hadn't seen each other since
the reunion until bravocon which is sad
but it was probably six weeks which oh
think about when the reunion films it's
not that many weeks ago oh yeah that's
true but it's still a long time to not
see her sister who lives in the same
city as you right but people get busy
with lives it's not that it's not like a
year which is what it felt like at first
but I'm like wait maybe two months I am
curious though like where we go from
here because Kathy's been very clear
that in under no circumstances would she
returned to the show if Rina and Erica
are both there she said Erica I saw it
now TMZ she told Erica am I the only one
who's had an about face about Erica
um no you're not because honestly like
some of the [ __ ] she was saying let's
say like I kind of agreed with a lot of
the stuff she was saying throughout the
reunion about other people's issues not
even her own stuff like
yeah no she was giving like early Erica
shrews yeah no I didn't think what she
was saying was that crazy and I do think
like a lot of the women like are kind of
performative when it comes to like the
victims it's like well oh you're you
care so much like do what Diana did
raise some money like I do feel like
they're only pretending to care so that
the audience doesn't give them more [ __ ]
since they already stand with Erica and
did you feel like that's really phony of
them her her Achilles heel is her
friendship with Rena like she is making
like I I actually have started to like
respect what she says and like turn on
her a little bit but her friendship with
Rena is just diabolical like it's not
ever gonna make me really warm towards
her
yeah
it doesn't bother me so much as long as
she likes kind of stays out of yeah and
they did stay out of each other's big
business last night yeah she's not
getting into the victim stuff and Erica
was not getting into the Kathy stuff
right other than to say she heard Kathy
say that slur oh right but when it came
to the victim stuff I don't know I just
feel like she's starting to make more
sense to me in terms of where she's
coming from and yes it looks terrible
and unsympathetic but these people are
like it's so bound up in legal issues
that she has like really no wiggle room
not even to give sympathy yeah because
then that's acknowledging and those are
people who are suing her so she's it's
it's a very tough spot it's a really
tight line to walk and I actually think
she's walked it really well I think it's
become clear that she did not know no
yeah and that she like wasn't nefarious
in her doings yeah I'll always still
question why she happened to divorce Tom
like the same time after like a 15-year
marriage why she divorced him like the
same month this all came out yeah that's
my biggest question question
um but and at the time I thought it was
like they were faking divorce so that
they could hide assets yeah but they're
not getting back together and there's no
assets right to hide
um even though she wasn't like a
overwhelming presence garcelle was the
queen of the reunion of course um her
facial expressions the times that she
butted in were just so premium you know
when Lisa was like well that's between
you and Kathy and Kyle Kathy and Kyle
that's between you and so garcelle's
like well why the [ __ ] won't you get out
of it like why are you stepping it up
garcelle is just I feel like garcelle
has had a horrible season like like from
like she did not have a good time
um and I really feel like she would
leave the show because now it's like her
kids and like she's she doesn't [ __ ]
around with that I really hope she
doesn't I hope she gets a raise I I
could see a world in which she doesn't
return even though she's a fan favorite
because like [ __ ] went too far this year
and I really hope that's not the case I
think if I have to predict I think
she'll come back but we won't see her
kids on the show anymore yeah like I
think they'll never film again yeah
which I think is what a lot of the women
should do because the Bravo fan base
like after years and years has like
reached a boiling point where they're
not okay I feel like every reunion
there's a whole segment about the hate
the death threats it's like and they're
pointing fingers at each other for like
who's responsible but it's like maybe
the Psychopaths sending the death
threats are responsible yeah I don't
think and I don't think any of the women
really are behind sending each other
thoughts and this and that me neither
it's so it's so evil yeah the some of
the corners of the Bravo fandom are
really really dark yeah so if I was
coming on the show now I would not put
my kids on it yeah so I think that's
where Garcia will go because also the
real is over so she has like more time
than she's had and I think aside from
what went down this season like she's
enjoyed her time the fans love her I
think she enjoys being well received
that must feel really good yeah she's
had she has good friendships on this
show now I think that's the change that
she'll make and and I think that would
be appropriate but I would also
completely understand if she does
doesn't want to do it anymore right I'm
just curious where what with the
Renaissance stuff with the garcelle
stuff like what that means for casting
for next season but we'll just have to
wait insane so that was TV recap that is
our show I head over to
shopmorningtoast.com if you want to grab
a TMT sorority sweatshirt this is
probably going to be maybe our final
restock because we are now like the
toast even though like this is always in
forever and I'll be wearing the
sweatshirt until the day I die I'm
wearing it on my deathbed in the nursing
home
um and we also launched onesies for your
little baby girls and boys
shopmorningtoast.com thank you so much
for listening to the toast the
Millennium Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up then you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up saying
we're wickedly talented the podcast is
hosted by the wickedly talented
all the places so if you listen to
podcast find us to tell us leave a five
star review about a beautiful stunning
and smart we are hope you guys have it
in Korea Thursday and we'll see you
tomorrow for the final show of the week
because it
Friday Friday gonna get down on Friday
everybody is looking forward to the
weekend weekend Friday Friday getting
down on strategy this is Charlie demilio
no it's Dixie
um we'll see you guys tomorrow bye